hi I think this is our new video
JC Shaw's a Lance Bass Joey Fatone
Justin Timberlake and Chris Kirkpatrick
in full doll makeup not just gloss it's
not sweat I'm not I'm cool on the set of
there it's gonna be me music video the
year was 2000 and only et was with them
well we are here today filming extra
b-roll vignette footage where we're
actually inside the toy store because
that's the whole setup of the video for
it's gonna be me it's a lot of fun we've
been in rouen makeup for like four hours
and it's worth it I mean it's it's gonna
come out good on camera so this video we
kind of interrupted our rehearsals for
the tour
so you know m'as happening at once but
you know it's time for the second single
to come out and so we're doing a video
for justin referring to instincts
sophomore album no-strings-attached
which dropped 20 years ago it sold 2.4
million records in the first week and
over 11 million in total making it
billboards top album of the decade it's
exciting for us I mean on top of that we
were just excited that this is our first
number-one album now here's the back
story no strings attached dropped at the
height of boyband pandemonium almost
immediately following instincts legal
battle against their founder and manager
Lou Pearlman so it became their way of
saying we're not anyone's puppet
[Music]
it's metaphor that played out visually
in the music video for their first
single yeah I mean everybody contributes
you know that's that's what it's all
about
[Music]
The Ballad this I promise you also join
the ranks of hits off
no-strings-attached but it's gonna be me
within sinks only song to peek at the
number one position on the US Billboard
Hot 100 at this point we feel like the
sky's the limit if we can think of it we
can make it happen it's kind of like you
know if you can believe it you can do it
and that's kind of the attitude we've
taken on lately it's just like if we can
see it in our heads we feel like we can
make it happen
all right now writing on the boxes
I think Lansing or Joey I originally
came up with the concept and once you
know somebody comes up with a concept
for a video we all just start rolling
with ideas and coming with with
everything we can that's it all that for
that let's go wait for another five
hours well basically it's a domino thing
and we knock down some dominoes and
those are gonna start heading towards us
so we run out of the way before
[Music]
it's gonna be me debuted on TRL on May
23rd mm the glue fumes are getting to
our brain here pull my cord no answer
any question you want
hi my name is Chris I'm a very good I
like to fight
I like fine women long walks in the park
and beaches it's gonna be me
[Music]